we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p our
voicemail line is made possible by our
very good friends over at linguist who
make it possible to learn a foreign
language very quickly with their
personalized spaced repetition ai
algorithm I've been rehashing my French
and I've improved very quickly you can
try it out for free with no credit card
at Ling viscom slash Pakman that's Li ng
vis t.com slash Pakman thanks to them
for sponsoring the voice mail segment
and with no further delay let's get on
to a voicemail I offended someone or I
guess a guest offended someone a caller
offended someone in the audience here is
why they were offended hey David I was
surprised that you let that caller who
called in about 25 minutes into your
show who cost like 4 to 6 times he used
the GD word and you didn't call him off
I was kind of offended by that I really
didn't like him as a caller the way he
said it and the fact that he did say it
I think he knew he was doing and he had
no intention of saying anything to have
substance so when people like that call
either because they think they can get
you to pay some kind of fine if he's
he's fine depending on whether you go
out to broadcast stations or not I would
cut them off immediately and not clip
with their nonsense okay have a good
night okay
so there's a couple different issues
here one is someone being individually
offended by the use of the term goddamn
as far as allowing it in the FCC stuff
it's allowed by the FCC I mean it's not
the guidance we've gotten is that we
don't have to worry about that it's the
same as when if someone just says you're
acting like a horse's ass that's allowed
for our type of programming on the
stations that were on but if someone
turns that into the 7-letter version of
the word that is not allowed so there's
kind of two different issues here our
broadcast stations are fine that it so
that you're allowed to say that there's
not going to be any
FCC fines for that and number two in
terms of being offended I mean I'm sorry
I don't know its language people use we
don't really do that it it may not be
language that I regularly use but we're
not gonna cut a call out of the show
because somebody use that word so I'm
sorry I'm sorry if people were offended
and I'm not being sarcastic when I say
that I'm not actually apologizing for a
caller's use of the word but I feel bad
if if somebody was offended we've got a
great bonus show for you today david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show I will speak to
you on the bonus show